how's it going relented welcome back I
went up recording god damnit welcome
back to South Park I bet you didn't
expect this [ __ ] dead yet this little
bonus for you bros for being so awesome
during this series and supporting it I
feel like the least I can do is actually
finish the game cuz we were actually
pretty damn close I just kind of felt
like it was it really worth it
you bros said yes so I'm gonna do it for
you just for you baby alright so we have
three quests
left as far as I'm concerned let's start
off by finding that goddamn hobo at last
hope well I'm not gonna cheat her
anything
so [ __ ] how to find it alas I'm not
chatting and honestly I I miss this game
I'm sad it's over but there will be DLC
for the game at least that's what the
menu screen hints so that's good
alright there supposed to be a trail
here somewhere here we go
oh there it is oh my god I knew that out
of sheer coincidence because I'm just
like a psychic genius from the space
future
all right let's he's supposed to be here
some committee a little hobo okay Alfred
do they have sex with you butters god
damn pervert oh hey there's this what is
happening what's with that what is what
what is HAP what okay I just happened
I'm gonna restart my recording alright
[ __ ] it
plagues are Egypt these [ __ ]
okay that's not working very well that's
not working well yeah there we go that's
pretty good
haha finished about us I'm not the
she'll I don't need the shield
god damn you Betty alright fine oh great
I don't even have to blog yeah that's
the sign I make oh really oh oh boy oh
boy
so we found seven out of seven now we
can return to may your McDaniels after
we load all these [ __ ]
alright City Hall baby alright thanks
kid your work helping with the homeless
of South Park will never be forgotten
here's your cash nice we can almost
impart a nose job actually maybe we can
we can I guess why not all right let's
get that go on through door to your
right I don't know if I want to do with
this now hi I'm dr. Tom I understand you
want some work done just have a seat
right here all right just relax this
won't hurt a bit until I started with
more tournaments
my god right if I come back if you ever
need me no way what the fine seriously I
might gonna look like this yeah Devin
all right next quest let's not get side
ok find all the underpants what have I
done to my buddy sorry too got a dumbest
thing ever okay so apparently there's
Underpants in every house on this street
is a room here okay please I need
Underpants why my underpants you say my
underpants three out of five baby just
flew right in my pocket all right two
more oh hello I have no idea what you
did
Mew quest oh okay yeah find a flower for
Kenny they said oh my god it's my it's
my little guy say it's nothing wrong
with having one of us it's like you
don't understand
I want that fun hi Jesus Christ why do I
have to explore I'm now terrified him
looking farther it isn't logical to
abandon the bridge until the captain
returns do you [ __ ] know who I am
the captain is my BOB I can't go outside
when she's not home but the Federation
has an urgent mission for you a
tricorder was left behind on the frozen
planet of Hoth only it's not a tricorder
it's my
iPad - I need you to beam down to the
Omicron sector and locate that device
before it falls into Klingon hands I
think it fell out of my backpack near
the church Oh more quests okay cool
oh my god how did I miss that four out
of five baby all right all right what's
in here
a fourth nothing new here huh so glad I
check that I mean it wasn't done that
let's be honest yes oh my god
[ __ ] yeah we got all the underpants
alright where are they I forgot are they
in my house
go play with your son I'll give you $20
if you talk right now
daddy look you've made friends I'll be
your friend too sweetie
no thanks all right are they here
I got your stupid check I guess so
although in our arms and orphan gnomes
are created will surely forgive you now
I guess so I guess so all right what do
we have now I want to do this one last
flower for print princess Kenny perhaps
one can be found in Cartman's backyard
okay you can have this body anytime you
want David Hasselhoff what I'm your son
hope your new friends are well-behaved
watch out for strangers what's wrong
with that [ __ ] alright let's see if we
can find a flower here oh my god Benji's
Katie that fits nuggins definitely else
are growing outside all right there you
go
are we gonna have sex huh is that it oh
we got alright well that's almost the
same alright what's next Vulcan search a
area around the church for Kevin's iPad
right where is that iPad oh that was
easy oh I was way too hot
I'm surprised out damn fast I found it
alright well let's go back to him I
guess by shuttle all right Kevin here
you go
let it be though than I have been and
will always be your friend
missile I'm slowing nice that's that's
high that's just [ __ ] hot
now with that got that taken care of we
have one more job to do and that's
big-game hunting with the Jimbo and it's
not gonna be easy I woulda did one of
them supposed to be one here maybe here
yeah we go oh god what is that what is
that oh no I don't want to kill a dog
maybe you don't look I hope I'll just
use my manbearpig car
I got a baby oh god yes so much help
damn I thought as you better do
something good oh I didn't even do that
much
[Music]
I grow some balls
I played the lead damage
it's like David Hasselhoff it's it's
like look at Mike away finishing matters
[Music]
all right that takes care of two and I
got a new message son Kenny oh my god
like if you think I'm the fairest maiden
in the land what do I like out of my
life so you can actually hear it
understand Kenny on Facebook all right
next one is here
Oh God in the sewers guess we have no
choice I don't like the sewers there we
go all right
oh [ __ ] what the what the [ __ ] is that
South Park creators warning hi this is
Kelly quick you man what's that a penis
mouse
a [ __ ] penis mouse
I don't even know anymore man all right
but why it's the [ __ ] penis goddamn
he [ __ ] you hard man okay let's
circumcised that penis mouse animal okay
better be bleeding oh yeah it [ __ ]
dies oh yeah oh my god that [ __ ] is over
so that was the thing that was up there
got that right
alright what's next
why do we do it blood sucking what okay
I actually know a shortcut
there it is can we go down here yes
awesome is this yeah it has to be this
one yes we put a blood orange there nice
[Music]
ok I got a feeling we want to kill this
guy quick finish him David fling up
David early huh Stephen better now okay
but us you can shock him you dirty
flight course you do I love that blood
orange orange poop blood eggs blood
Aaron's poop i loved-ed a blood orange
poop it's very good and I wonder if or
anyone ever said that in her life I love
that blood orange poop
just like that blood orange I love that
blood adings poop I love that blood
having school
I feel so unique right now my hipster
senses are tingling
one more it's over no wait yeah it's in
school yes it's in here so I know this
is in a South Park episode but isn't it
from all surface that's disgusting that
movie with the lion wood oh god am I
gonna have to kill hi
I hope suckers all right this should it
go quickly
[Music]
damn nice one - yeah alright with that a
did it alright the last one is in Canada
I love how Canadians act in this show is
so funny okay so let's go to Canada I
heard it's great this time of year
not so many direwolf's if you're lucky
that is on that poor cow that was the
first one I did I just hit it once and
he died and hadn't wanted to it oh god I
hate the Dyer [ __ ] I hate those they're
so annoying let's cover Cartman here
inside kill [ __ ] all of them
[Applause]
David Hasselhoff is very pleased
I've been looking for freedom since I
left my home town looking for a dumb
still surge goes on
I don't know I don't know the [ __ ]
lyrics alright we're in Canada this is
not how you speaking Katie there I don't
know why dick
whatever it's goddamn dire beer so I
hate every there pretty [ __ ] like I'm
pretty [ __ ] cow it's [ __ ] sound
where they died what the hell oh God
alright can we do it without ranting
into that Dyer ah alright we did it we
did it we can do it we can do it we can
do it
Bennett alright what are we gonna fight
what is that yeah I think we've got
enough guys already I think so too bad
we gotta finish this one alright what is
it a barking spider what the [ __ ]
I make me proud Cartman and that's how
it's done all right we're done I just
don't want to run into that wolf I got
I'm scared yes
Ottawa see you later alligator hey miss
Jamie Hajis now we just have to get back
I wish it was a teleporting here but
there isn't ah man way back baby
back in black baby I think baby
Siobhan's Bobby
what can I do for you do kid so well I
didn't really ship with it I wouldn't
like to yes
hey saint head mouse was making us all
look bad in more ways than one in it
this big for yourself alright looks like
that bad sucked its last fruit haha nice
work I remember when I bag by first
that's this [ __ ] da bane you're probably
the best hunter this town's ever seen
right up there with bayonet at all prime
right dead straight up alright quest is
done we got his key what does that go
where does that go how and you know what
that means for us there all done there
are a lot of achievements or whatever
there are more content but this is
really all I wanted to do I said I was
gonna do all the side quests and I did a
lot of side quests I don't think it's
that fun to watch me just trying to find
all the achievements and stuff like that
that's I don't know that doesn't make
sense to me unless there's actual
content behind it so
without further ado for the third time
thank you for so much for watching this
series I'll see you when the DLC comes
out I should be pretty awesome and I
hope you enjoyed this little bonus it
your nose like when the episode is over
see he comes like yeah give me attention
now [ __ ] I got a Google to make sure
there's no quest that I missed
um also a lot of us have been asking
about my headphones they're from Razer
they're definitely my favorite
headphones that I ever used so if you
want a pair of these for a cheaper price
you can check the link in description
and add the code edgar is really excited
for these and you get them for free
shipping and a little discount so that's
pretty cool so yeah definitely go check
that out and thank you for watching
that's it sales embrace love you
[Music]